[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
Dragon Ball super video in this video we
will be talking about Vegeta and how his
behavior during the tournament of power
might suggest that he is hiding a secret
a secret that could turn into a major
plot twist sometime soon to be honest
for a while now I've been thinking that
some of Vegeta's actions during the
tournament of power have been a bit odd
including his refusal to contribute
energy to Goku spirit bomb when even
Frieza decided to help out and also the
way Vegeta has remained calm and
confident even after witnessing the
incredible power of both Gian and ultra
instinct Goku has struck me as a bit
strange in the past when he came across
a much stronger opponent Vegeta wouldn't
remain calm and he would actually feel
intimidated such as when he first
encountered beerus in Dragon Ball super
but during the tournament of power
Vegeta seems to be perfectly confident
even after witnessing the awesome power
of jiren who at this point as far as we
know should be far stronger than Vegeta
not only that but in episode 114 we get
the biggest clue yet that Vegeta is
hiding something big
while Topo is commenting on the fight
between Goku and Khalifa and kale and
talking about how powerful the Saiyans
are Vegeta actually says to topple there
is something you should know among the
Saiyans I stand at the top
now why would Vegeta say this so
directly if he wasn't really hiding
something some ace up his sleeve could
it be that during his training in the
hyperbolic time chamber Vegeta was able
to gain greater control of his key and
unlock some sort of hidden power that we
still don't know about these are the
type of questions we're gonna be talking
about in this video and of course if you
want to see more Dragon Ball super Kong
here on the channel be sure to leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell while
doing research online about what secret
vegeta might be hiding I came across a
video by a youtuber named element 7 in
which he claims that vegeta already
attained ultra instinct but we just
don't know it yet I will leave a link to
that video in the description if you
want to check it out but to summarize
element 7 believes that vegeta has been
deliberately conserving his stamina
throughout the tournament and this could
be because vegeta already attained ultra
instinct back in the hyperbolic time
chamber before the tournament began but
he is hiding it in order to keep the
element of surprise according to this
video the reason majeeda doesn't seem
angry or jealous of Goku after Goku
attains ultra instinct and instead
merely asks Goku if he knows what
happened is because Vegeta already went
through the same transformation that
Goku went through now I don't know if
this exact theory about ultra instinct
is true but I definitely think that
Vegeta is hiding something important
let's not forget that Vegeta knows how
high the stakes are during this
tournament he knows that his wife and
children will die if universe 7 doesn't
win so why does he seem to be so calm
and confident even after witnessing how
powerful cheerin is we know that Vegeta
has a lot of pride and honour as a
Saiyan so I really don't think that he
would just outright lie to topo and tell
him that he was at the top of all the
Saiyans if he didn't have some good
reason to believe that he really was the
real question is what exactly is vegeta
hiding what ace does he have up his
sleeve right now is it ultra instinct a
different technique we haven't seen
before
or maybe a new form altogether could it
be that the real reason Vegeta didn't
contribute energy to Goku spirit bomb is
because his ki has changed in some way
and he doesn't want the others to sense
this change
did we steeped Regina some secret
technique that Goku and the others don't
even know about there are definitely a
lot of questions out there but one thing
is for sure Vegeta fans get ready
because he is definitely hiding
something big and I am sure that he is
going to play a much bigger role in the
near future
in fact with the recent introduction of
the Patara earrings to the tournament
with kale and khalifa using them to fuse
into kefla just imagine how powerful
ultra instinct Goku and ultra instinct
Vegeta
would be if they got their hands on the
Patara and fuse if the cheetah really
does have ultra instinct or if he
obtains it soon and he fuses with Goku
that is definitely away for universe 7
fighters to stand up to jiren and that
type of epic fusion could definitely be
the solution to this problem of G R and
being so OB furthermore as I mentioned
in my every Saiyan form explained video
if we look at the appearance of Goku
with ultra instinct it can be compared
to the Super Saiyan God form in terms of
hairstyle which is in turn similar to
the base form or a Super Saiyan except
for the differences in hair color if we
accept that Super Saiyan God form is the
base form of a Saiyan that possesses
godly ki with Super Saiyan blue being
the Super Saiyan version of ass and with
godly ki then we can speculate that this
ultra instinct form with silver eyes
that we have seen briefly is merely a
base form of a new branch of
transformation we can hypothesize that
if ultra instinct is merely a base form
there will be a Super Saiyan version of
ultra instinct sometime in the future
just like the Super Saiyan blue is the
Super Saiyan version of the Super Saiyan
God form
personally I think that this Super
Saiyan version of ultra instinct might
be called Super Saiyan ultra or
something along those lines but whatever
this next stage is called could it be
possible that Vegeta already attained
this Super Saiyan version of ultra
instinct if so it would make sense for
him not to be worried about jiren since
the Super Saiyan version of ultra
instinct would likely be far more
powerful than anything we've seen from
cheerin so far and of course in that
case Vegeta would have no reason to be
jealous of Goku for attaining ultra
instinct because Vegeta
might secretly be one step ahead of Goku
obviously we can't say for sure just yet
the whole point right now seems to be to
keep us in the dark and keep us guessing
about what Vegeta is hiding but if
Vegeta has secretly been the strongest
saying the one at the top of all the
Saiyans then we are in for some
spectacular plot twists and Vegeta is
finally going to get the spotlight he
deserves but those are just some of my
thoughts let me know what you guys think
down in the comments what is Vegeta
hiding why did he tell topo that he is
actually at the top of all of the
Saiyans and what secret power could he
be hiding let me know down below if you
enjoyed these videos and want to see
more don't forget to leave a like to let
me know if you are new to the channel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and of course feel
free to let me know what kind of Dragon
Ball super content you want to see in
the future right here at anime uproar I
have to thank my good friend Kid Chi for
helping out with this and other videos I
gotta say that as a longtime fan of
Dragon Ball Z who grew up with Dragon
Ball Z I was skeptical about Dragon Ball
super I didn't know if it was just gonna
be a cash grab and I didn't know
if I could trust them to do a good job
for this reason I was actually pretty
late getting into Dragonball super but I
have to thank my friend Kid Kai and also
my brother goes in for getting me into
it
they also grew up on Dragonball Z just
like me so they knew where I was coming
from but they started watching Dragon
Ball super and they told me that I need
to get into it it definitely has some
awesome moments and I shouldn't miss out
I was skeptical at first I hesitated I
resisted it but in the end I gave in and
I'm definitely glad that I did I
especially loved all the strategy that
is coming into play in Dragon Ball super
especially now during the tournament of
power there is definitely a lot more
strategy involved now than there was
back in the Dragon Ball Z days it's not
just about being the strongest and
having the strongest power level in the
tournament of power you have to learn to
work together as a team you have to
watch out for special skills and
techniques and I think that this has
really made things a lot more
interesting but that is just my quick
take on Dragon Ball super and how I got
into it in the first place definitely
want to give a huge thank you to all of
you who have been supporting our Dragon
Ball super content here on the channel
the next video that we're gonna publish
on Dragon Ball super is gonna be about
kale and cauliflower and how they manage
to grow their power levels so fast
during this tournament although it might
seem crazy how fast kale and Khalifa
have been growing during this tournament
and especially when compared to the
universe seven Saiyans and everything
they have to go through to get where
they are I think there is actually some
logic as to why they were able to
advance so quickly and that is what I
will be talking about in the next video
as always thank you so much for watching
and until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]